there have been places and periods of
history
when only a congenital optimist could
have had any hope
for the future of our species think of
the end of athens's golden age
the fall of the roman empire the
petering out of the renaissance the end
of the enlightenment
the rise of fascism it's when things
look bleak indeed
that it pays to remember the german 19th
century philosopher
hegel in his lectures on the philosophy
of world history
published in 1830 hegel offered us a way
of looking at the darker periods of
history
that neither glosses over that pain nor
refuses to give up hope
but intelligently helps us to understand
why human progress
cannot be linear while encouraging us to
trust that it does occur
nevertheless for hegel history moves
forward in what he termed
a dialectical way a dialectic
is a philosophical term for an argument
made up of three parts
a thesis an antithesis and a synthesis
both the thesis and the antithesis
contain parts of the truth
but there are also exaggerations and
distortions of the whole
and so need to clash and interact until
their best elements
find resolution in a synthesis one
cannot
in short get there in one leap hegel
thought this pattern constantly
observable in history
the world makes progress by lurching
from one extreme to another
as it seeks to overcompensate for a
previous mistake
and generally requires three moves
before the right balance
on any issue can be found so for example
the ancient athenians
discovered the idea of individual
liberty but their regime was blind to
the need for collective discipline and
organization
the ancient persians knew all about that
and were thereby able to conquer the
athenians on the battlefield
yet they were also despotic enemies of
free thought
which with time became its own liability
it took many centuries for the correct
synthesis between liberty and discipline
to be worked out in the form of the
roman empire
in hegel's own era the stifling unfair
18th century system of inherited
traditional monarchy
had been abolished by the french
revolution but what should have been the
peaceful birth of representative
government
ended up in the anarchy and chaos of the
terror
this in turn led to the emergence of
napoleon who restored order but became a
military brute
trampling on the liberty he had
professed to love only after 40 years
and much bloodshed
did the modern balanced constitution
emerge an arrangement which more
sensibly balanced up
popular representation with the rights
of minorities
or to take another example the european
enlightenment had stressed the
importance of reason
but it had in many parts been sterile
and reductive
the movement known as romanticism had
then swept in to assert the importance
of emotion
but this had carried excesses of its own
only eventually
had a correct reconciliation been worked
out between the legitimate competing
needs
of reason and emotion hegel's argument
has a highly reassuring feel at moments
when it seems that one kind of progress
has been entirely lost he is on hand to
reassure us that we're merely seeing the
pendulum swing back for a time
but also wisely counseled that this was
needed because the initial move forward
had been blind to a range of crucial
insights
all sides on a matter will contain
important truths
lodged amidst exaggeration and bombast
yet these truths
will eventually be sifted out through
the wisdom of time
hegel reminds us that big overreactions
are eminently compatible
with events broadly moving forward in
the right direction
the dark moments aren't the end they are
a challenging but even in some ways
necessary parts
of an antithesis that will eventually
find a wiser point of synthesis
you